your dna is constantly changing
and if it were for genetic mutations
evolution wouldn't exist
so
what would life be like if that stopped
what causes your dna to change
how would your life immediately change
without genetic mutations
and
what would happen to humanity in the
long run
this is what if and here's what would
happen if our dna stopped mutating
dna is short for
deoxyribonucleic acid
and even though 99
of your dna is the same as everybody
else
it's the instruction manual for what
makes you you
dna is what makes up your genome
your genome contains 3 billion bases
20 000 genes and 23 pairs of chromosomes
half you inherit from the sperm of your
father and the other half from the egg
of your mother
dna provides directions for your body to
make different proteins you need for
your health growth and development
so if that genetic evolution stopped
would this lead to the eventual
extinction of humankind
did i mention your dna is constantly
mutating oh yeah
well before you get too excited
no i don't mean any x-men type of
mutations
your dna mutations are changes that
occur in the sequence of a gene
some of them are good for you some of
them are bad
most are neutral okay
mutations are a natural part of dna
replication
most of the time your dna sequences
replicate without any errors but
sometimes
mistakes happen
mutations occur when nucleotides the
basic building blocks of dna are added
deleted or incorrectly exchanged in a
sequence
entire segments of dna could translocate
or move from one chromosome to another
they could even be replicated in an
inverted structure of the original
sequence
you could inherit genetic mutations from
your parents you could acquire them from
environmental agents like ultraviolet
radiation and certain chemicals
your genes can even mutate by chance
but your dna does have methods for
recognizing these imperfections
special repair enzymes cut out the wrong
pieces and replace them with the right
ones
but
some of these mistakes get through and
become permanent
at this point your cells would no longer
recognize them as errors
mutations in your body's cells could
impact your life development and
well-being
these random unpredictable dna mistakes
account for nearly two-thirds of the
mutations in cancers
but in order to be passed on genetic
variants would need to occur through
reproduction
this is called hereditary variation
and it's what makes evolution possible
so if mutations in your dna stopped
you'd no longer benefit from some of the
mutations that occur
if you're an athlete you won't get the
so-called sports gene
this mutation in the actn3 gene affects
muscle fibers responsible for fast
tensing or flexing
geneticists have found that elite
sprinters and power athletes are less
likely to have defective copies of this
gene than the general public
another example is a mutation linked to
higher levels of good cholesterol a
mutation in the gene that produces the
cetp protein can cause a deficiency that
could cause a lower prevalence of
coronary heart disease
but with all of the positive mutations
out of the picture you'd also no longer
suffer from negative mutations
genetic disorders like cystic fibrosis
wouldn't pass on to new generations
and if our cells didn't mutate then
cancers would also cease to exist you're
cancer-free without these conditions the
human lifespan could
increase but we'd be ushering in a new
era of life without biological evolution
natural selection only operates or
doesn't operate after a mutation occurs
if that mutation is beneficial to the
survival of a species it becomes more
common over time
that means
we'd need to develop other forms of
evolution to keep our species from dying
out
meanwhile the other animals and plants
would continue to evolve
maybe the food you eat today would no
longer be substantial for survival
look at lactose tolerance
most mammals lose their ability to
digest lactose before adulthood
but for many humans this ability
persists
this is due to a mutation in the lct
gene
ten thousand years ago our diets changed
profoundly with the domestication of
plants and animals
people who were able to better digest
these new foods had a genetic advantage
if we could no longer adapt to new diets
we'd have to develop new technologies to
make food that could sustain our species
well if we can already make lactose-free
milk maybe there's no end to the ways we
can survive without genetic mutations
but
good or bad
these little errors are what makes us
who we are
still it wouldn't be as bad as that time
we made your dna disappear
yeah that's a story
for another
what if